a Kentucky state lawmaker accused of
molesting a teenager is dead from an
apparent suicide
police say 57 year old Dan Johnson shot
himself yesterday on a bridge not far
from his home outside Louisville a day
earlier he denied molesting a 17 year
old in 2013
mark Strassmann is outside the State
Capitol in Frankfort mark good morning
good morning Johnson a preacher for the
last 40 years was elected state Rep here
last November
since these allegations surfaced leaders
from both state parties have urged him
to resign now police will investigate
why he apparently took his own life
police found Dan Johnson just outside
his car Wednesday night with a single
gunshot wound to the head someone saw
his post on social media and alerted the
law enforcement and that Facebook post
about two hours before his death Johnson
wrote the accusations are false PTSD is
a sickness that will take my life I
cannot handle it any longer
on Monday the Kentucky Center for
Investigative Reporting published an
article alleging that in 2013 Johnson
molested then 17-year old girl from his
church at a New Year's party Johnson
allegedly slid his hands up under her
shirt and bra and groped her and forced
his hands down her pants Johnson denied
the account during a sermon Tuesday and
refused to resign this allegation
concerning this this lady this young
girl absolutely has no merit there are
people that have have had abuse but at
the same time I think that there's been
people that have have taken that
political shocks Johnson was elected to
the state legislature in 2016 under an
umbrella of scrutiny in 1985 he was
indicted in an insurance fraud scheme
after he admitted to paying people to
torch his own car it's a place where he
reportedly was cited three times for
selling alcohol from his church without
a liquor license and just three months
before his election Johnson posted
photos on Facebook of the Obamas
depicted as monkeys at the time he
called them not racist but satire last
night Kentucky governor Matt Bevin
tweeted saddened to hear of tonight's
death of Kentucky representative Dan
Johnson my heart breaks for his family
tonight Johnson's autopsy is scheduled
for later today
gaile all right thank you thank you Mark